five 117 Russell Crowe be trying to use
the Carol's green penetration shovel the
throw and it's out of bounds off of
Brooklyn they will take a look with
under two minutes left I'm sorry Carol
dumping off that's just a tough one
great block two guys going extremely
hard as long as what you want to say you
got to finish that up here Jared Allen
but you can't disrespect the great
defensive play by Bravo fast
Bobby afro is off the throw telling you
that's why I've had a shaved head since
I was 11 that's not why it's a lot of a
good complete mature male balding but
that is why the fro I mean look it's
part of his signature but if he had less
hair gets off Milwaukee agree any
advantage that I could get any misses
you could get even if that means no hair
do you think that'll make them
reevaluate it I do not I don't think so
but it literally was off the throw he's
like you know when they say hand a part
of the ball is like the throw count yeah
body the throw is if it hits like a
frayed or afro yeah any part it will be
Bucks basketball confirmed with 153 left